I mean I would like to be my own soul
mate why I would think so I think
Rachel's gonna be my soul mate okay so
which unreal character is your soul mate
hugg Gear martini vodka soda
margarita wine or whiskey I'm gonna go
miss a wine Oh Gillian come margarita
just feels like summery fresh Drake Kim
Kardashian Ryan Gosling Blake Lively
Leonardo DiCaprio or Beyonce oh that's
the stuff I want Leo and I want Bay I'm
gonna go for being soon
Mugabe Fiji Islands Paris Cancun New
York City Amalfi Coast or the Bahamas
Amalfi Coast please sounds lovely sounds
fantastic leaves you high I know what
you're thinking you're thinking one of
those hot over the walk that's right
exactly seeing a movie romantic dinner
Drake sit bar picnic in the park hiking
by the way is not a romantic date
there's nothing that sounds more fun
than being outside and listening to some
good music come on picnic in the park
lobster Wrangler millennial chicken
enthusiast hmm a free spirit time to do
free spirit I'm a free spirit you guys
anything value plus Rachel a match made
in heaven seeing her work those
storylines turns you on your notes as
long as you aren't the storyline enjoy
your kind of messed up but never boring
life together this is what fate looks
like you and J together using the
mansion as your own playground with
fillings over oh of course I get
somebody gay as my soul mates
welcome to my life I'll make out with
you alright great here okay
huh